secondo voi quali sono i componenti
fondamentali di un'orchestra
io penso che siano tre prima di tutto
abbiamo bisogno degli strumenti
in secondo luogo abbiamo bisogno di dei
musicisti di qualcuno che suoni gli
strumenti come ad esempio del violinista
che premendo l'archetto sulle corde del
violino permette di far uscire la musica
dallo strumento ma penso che queste due
cose non bastino non bastano gli
strumenti e non bastano i musicisti ci
vuole una terza componente che è il
maestro se non ci fosse il maestro i
musicisti andrebbero per la loro strada
e verrebbe fuori un gran baccano è
necessario avere un maestro da seguire
in modo che tutti questi strumenti
vadano insieme nell'orchestra ora io
lavoro in una specie di orchestra
i musicisti sono le collisioni di
protoni prodotte dal large hadron
collider lhc e gli strumenti sono gli
esperimenti costruiti lì dove le
collisioni avvengono noi non produciamo
musica anche se c'è qualcuno che si è
divertito a prendere i nostri dati
qualche scienziato che ha preso i nostri
dati li ha trasformati musica ma no io
non faccio musica anche se mi piacerebbe
quello che facciamo noi e andare a
studiare i componenti fondamentali della
materia andare a capire come questi
interagiscono tra di loro come si
comportano e ci sono molte cose che
della natura ancora non capiamo e il
nostro studio è volto a capire come la
natura funziona e uno dei risultati di
queste ricerche ad esempio è stato
trovare il famoso bosone di higgs e
spero di spiegarmi nel seguito e farvi
capire che cos'è perché è così
importante e league la grande orchestra
su cui io lavoro sta a ginevra in
svizzera al cern il cern il centro
europeo per la ricerca nucleare
è stato fondato nel 1954 per cui nel
secondo dopoguerra quando gli stati
europei avevano appena smesso di farsi
la guerra e hanno cercato di ri
collaborare insieme fondando questo
centro italia è stato uno di 12 paesi
fondatori adesso il cern conta e 20
paesi membri europei e anche un'altra
sessantina di altri stati non europei
che partecipano alle ricerche
questo è il luogo dove sta l'orchestra
ma abbiamo detto chi produce la musica
chi produce la musica el lhc large
hadron collider grande collisionatore di
adroni questo acceleratore di particelle
un acceleratore circolare lungo 27
chilometri che è stato costruito in un
tunnel che qui vedete nell'immagine a
cento metri di profondità e in questi
tubi blu vengono accelerati i protoni
che poi vengono fatti collidere cioè
vengono fatti scontrare in quattro punti
dell'acceleratore e in questi quattro
punti dell'acceleratore sono stati
costruiti grandi strumenti per vedere i
prodotti delle collisioni dei protoni e
questi quattro grossi strumenti si
chiamano alice a class lhcb e cms e io
in particolare lavoro su atlas atlas sta
per e droid lca pareggio che significa è
una macchina che sta al lhc ed è
toroidale ora cosa voglia direttore dal
e lo scopriremo più avanti
io ho iniziato a lavorare su questo
esperimento esattamente sette anni fa
nel dicembre del 2006 per la mia tesi
specialistica e perché sono finita lì
mentre facevo studiamo fisica
all'università ho fatto un corso di
fisica nucleare da cui mi sono molto
appassionata e in questo corso
studiavamo come sono come si comportano
i fondamenti della materia come si
comportano le particelle e come queste
interagiscono tra di loro e li ho
imparato che
ci sono delle regole matematiche che
tutte le particelle sempre particelle
seguono per cui data la formula
matematica potete capire potete dedurre
come le particelle interagiranno tra di
loro ea me questo sembrava fenomenale
che noi potessimo andare a conoscere una
natura così in profondità e con così
tanta precisione ma l'altra cosa che mi
impressionava tantissimo e mi
interessavano ancora di più era il fatto
che più studiavo più capivo che ci sono
un sacco di cose che queste formule
matematiche quelle che conosciamo ancora
non spiegano come la materia oscura
oppure dieci anni fa quando io studiavo
quelle cose
si sapeva che il bosone di higgs era
probabile che esistesse ma non si era
ancora visto per cui noi io studiavo
cose che in qualche modo prima o poi
avremmo potuto vedere e io volevo essere
io volevo essere una di quelle che
diceva abbiamo visto l'abbiamo trovato
lo sapevamo che c'era eccolo ma non solo
da sola a lavorare su questo esperimento
siamo atlas è una collaborazione di
tremila persone che vengono da 38 paesi
diversi è una cosa molto interessante è
il fatto che il 20 per cento delle di
queste tremila persone hanno molta
vitamina d e se andiamo a guardare le
persone sotto i 30 anni
vogliono solo più tra quelle però ci
sono altre persone sotto i 30 anni nel
nostro esperimento il 30 per cento
la vitamina d che è una percentuale
abbastanza alta se pensate alla fisica
che tendenzialmente è ritenuto un luogo
per uomini e in questa mappa potete
vedere quali paesi partecipano
all'esperimento ad esempio io adesso
lavoro per un'università americana di
boston university
quindi in teoria dovrei stare in america
e ad esempio il mio fidanzato lavora per
universitari taiwan che sa esattamente
dall'altra parte del globo per cui
sarebbero 12 ore di fuso orario ma
grazie al cielo lavoriamo tutti e due a
ginevra per cui non abbiamo
molte difficoltà per sentirci per lo
meno ma dunque come come è fatto questo
esperimento perché abbiamo bisogno di
strumenti diversi bene se pensate
all'orchestra che facile pensare è stato
l'orchesta senza violini cosa sarebbe
una sinfonia senza violini si capisce
che mancherebbe qualcosa per un
esperimento di fisica delle particelle
funziona esattamente alla stessa maniera
in natura esistono diversi tipi di
particelle e servono diversi strumenti
per vedere queste particelle per cui se
uno un esperimento non ha un certo
strumento ad esempio per vedere gli
elettroni noi con quell esperimento gli
elettroni non li vedremo per cui è
importante quando si progetta un
esperimento mettere degli strumenti che
ci permettono di guardare tutte le
particelle possibili ora ma come ha
fatto a class atlas è stato costruito in
una caverna a cento metri di profondità
lì dove i protoni si riscontrano ha un
diametro di 25 metri ed una lunghezza di
46 metri
queste sono le dimensioni di metà della
cattedrale di notre dame a parigi il
peso di atlas e 7.000 tonnellate
se vogliamo stare a parigi la tour
eiffel e la struttura metallica da tour
eiffel pesa 7 mila tonnellate per cui è
una roba veramente emessa in queste
immagini potete forse scorgere degli
omini ecco quegli omini sono in scala
esperimento su cui lavoro io è grande
così
ma come è fatto e quali sono gli
strumenti che lo compongono
ora avrete visto che ha una struttura
abbastanza cilindri da mi piace pensarlo
un po come una cipolla una cipolla che
ha diversi strati e ogni strato serve a
vedere delle particelle diverse
ecco qui avete uno spaccato di come è
fatto l'esperimento ci sono diversi
strati e ogni strato serve a vedere
qualcosa di diverso ad esempio c'è un
sistema interno quello più vicino al
punto dove si scontrano i protoni che è
il sistema di tracciamento e io sono
particolarmente affezionata quello
perché ci ho lavorato per la mia tesi
sospeso quattro anni esternamente ci
sono poi c'è un campo magnetico che
permette di curvare le particelle
e poi ci sono altri altri strumenti che
si chiamano calorimetrica ad esempio
permettono di vedere gli elettroni e
fotoni o i protoni e poi all'esterno c'è
il famoso toroide quello che dà il nome
al nostro esperimento che nient'altro
che un grosso magnete molto grosso uno
dei più grandi mai costruiti e
all'esterno del troyes c'è un ulteriore
strumento che ci vede ci permette di
vedere una particella che scappa a tutti
strati della cipolla che ha attraversato
che sono immuni che sono semplicemente
dei fratelli più pesanti degli elettroni
ma ora cerchiamo di rivedere tutto da
capo ecco questo è il tunnel della lhc a
cento metri di profondità
i protoni girano all'interno di questi
tubi attraversano tranquillamente la
frontiera tra svizzera e francia come
faccio io
tutte le mattine per andare a lavorare
perché vivo in francia e lavoro svizzero
e poi si vanno a scontrare esattamente
lì dove abbiamo costruito i nostri
esperimenti esattamente lì dove abbiamo
costruito ad esempio atlas una nota
atlas è stato già iniziato a pensare a
questo esperimento circa negli anni 90
io ero ancora alle elementari e c'era
già gente che pensava all'esperimento su
cui io ho speso gli ultimi sette anni
della mia vita è quello che viene fuori
dalle collisioni sono queste tracce
colorate che abbiamo reso così per
renderle comprensibili a tutti è
un'immagine grafica di quello che
succede in realtà quello che noi vediamo
sono segnali elettrici e ogni quanto
avviene uno scontro del genere viene ad
avviene ogni 59 secondi se volete
vederlo in un'altra maniera significa
che avviene 20 milioni di volte al
secondo
venti milioni di volte al secondo voi
quando nate in vacanza fate tante
fotografie tendenzialmente non 20
milioni al secondo perché potrebbe
essere un po complicato però qui
comunque quante le fate voi tornati a
casa
prendete le fotografie di te ma questo
ci è passato davanti una persona questo
no questo è simile all'altra e iniziate
a buttarne via un po questo esattamente
quello che facciamo noi
noi abbiamo 20 milioni di collisioni
nel secondo per 60 secondi in un minuto
per 60 minuti in un'ora
24 ore al giorno e circa 200 giorni
all'anno perché 200 giorni all'anno sono
i giorni in cui noi prendiamo dati di
questi 20 milioni di collisioni al
secondo noi salviamo e teniamo da
guardare soltanto più o meno 600
collisioni al secondo perché
beh prima di tutto non avremo che spazio
per tenerne 20 milioni con l'igiene al
secondo per tutto l'anno
secondo luogo non avremo il tempo di
guardare a tutte queste ma la terza cosa
che escono vela più importante il fatto
che la fisica che vogliamo fare cioè
quello che io ho iniziato a voler
cercare dal mio corso all'università ad
esempio il bosone di higgs
capita molto più raramente di 20 milioni
di volte al secondo ad esempio il bosone
di higgs che decade ovvero si trasforma
in 4 elettroni avviene una volta ogni
tre ore
capite che non ci servono veramente 20
milioni di eventi al secondo
e allora mi chiederete ma scusa perché
allora non che quell evento ogni tre ore
e butti via gli altri perché mi 600 al
secondo che sono troppi sono tanti beh
perché comunque l'obiettivo di un
esperimento come quello su cui lavoro io
non è soltanto di vedere il bosone di
higgs e di cercare di capire il più
possibile come funziona la materia che
come funziona la realtà la natura per
cui teniamo il più possibile ovviamente
cosa interessante è quello è solo come
si presentano i nostri dati nei nostri
dati ci può essere qualcosa di nuovo e
inaspettato
oppure ci può essere qualcosa di nuovo e
aspettato io quando ho iniziato a fare
questo esperimento speravo che ci fosse
il bosone di higgs lo sapevo ma lo
speravo e il 4 luglio del 2012
finalmente abbiamo annunciato al mondo
il fatto che avevamo trovato il bosone
di higgs questo mix che si nascondeva
dentro dietro una tenda da quanto si
nascondeva si nascondeva da circa 50
anni perché phil brown e anne claire
anno postulato l'esistenza del bosone di
higgs circa nel
4 e perché l'hanno consulato perché si
rende il modello che spiegava come si
comportano le particelle e come queste
interagiscono tra di loro era perfetto
erano le formule matematiche di cui vi
parlavo prima funzionava tutto veramente
benissimo ma secondo questo modello non
le particelle non potevano avere massa
ma noi abbiamo massa le cose che abbiamo
davanti a massa e allora la massa da
dove viene e questi tre scienziati hanno
mostrato l'esistenza di questa nuova
particella che era quella che permetteva
alle altre di avere massa e per 50 anni
l'abbiamo cercato e l'abbiamo trovato e
un anno dopo la grande scoperta hanno
pensato bene di dare il premio nobel a
blair e hicks per aver postulato
l'esistenza del bosone di higgs ora vi
spiego un po perché da quando è iniziato
abbiamo iniziato a prendere dati con l
hc nel 2008 siamo riusciti a scoprire il
bosone di higgs soltanto nel 2012 come
che ci avete messo quattro anni
beh vi fate questo che ad esempio in
questo grafico che vedete la massa di
quattro leptoni 4 leptoni sono quattro
particelle simili agli elettroni
ora noi secondo il modello che
conosciamo sappiamo che quando abbiamo
due con una collisione di due protoni
possono essere prodotte tanti tipi di
particelle tra cui forse anche il bosone
di higgs e ci sono degli scontri che
producono 4 elettroni ad esempio è lo
scontro di questi ne protoni potrebbe
anche produrre unix che poi si
disintegra diciamo decade in quattro
elettroni
ora noi quello che conosciamo è la
distribuzione rossa cioè noi sappiamo
quali sono gli eventi che finiscono in
questa maniera i punti neri sono i
nostri dati per cui noi abbiamo una
predizione che quella rossa e poi
andiamo a vedere veramente i nostri dati
che sono quelli neri e vedete che c'è un
buco c'è un buco che viene spiegato bene
da quella distribuzione azzurra che è la
presenza del bosone di higgs per cui
attraverso queste immagini abbiamo
capito che
bosone di higgs c'era era lì ok adesso
che sappiamo che c'è il bosone di higgs
possiamo chiudere tutto e andare a casa
abbiamo finito no io voglio continuare e
tutti noi continuiamo perché in realtà
ci sono una gran quantità di cose che ha
ancora pur nonostante aver visto il
bosone di higgs noi lo conosciamo
ad esempio la materia oscura ma anche lo
stesso bosone di higgs necessita di
conferme perché ad esempio la nostra
scoperta è stata fatta con quattro
elettroni io quello che ho fatto
nell'ultimo anno diciamo giorno e notte
sabato e domenica lavorando abbastanza
pesantemente è stato coordinare un
gruppo di persone che cercasse il bosone
di higgs che decade cioè si trasforma in
due particelle tau sono dei fratelli
ancora più pesanti dell'elettrone e dopo
un anno di lavoro siamo riusciti
finalmente a trovarle questo è una delle
fotografie dove forse questo evento è un
mix che decade ntow tau per cui ad
esempio questo è stata una scoperta
abbiamo questa curiosità abbiamo
annunciato dieci giorni fa è stata una
scoperta fondamentale perché questa
veramente ci conferma che il bosone di
higgs che abbiamo visto è quello che ci
aspettavamo fare fisica per me è
un'avventura affascinante ha bisogno di
musicisti ha bisogno di strumenti ma ha
bisogno di persone che tutti i giorni si
sveglino e abbiano voglia di conoscere
di più come funziona la natura